it's a busy night ted new at 11 o'clock
residents in the far northwest valley
concerned for their safety tonight after
weeks of really strange behavior from
random people door knocking to car
break-ins thefts neighbors have had
enough and now they're speaking out
madison kimbrough joining us now live
from metro headquarters with their story
tonight madison
yeah for weeks residents of sky canyon
and providence concerned over the
bizarre happenings that have been
happening in their gated community and
while reports have been filed with metro
their hope is that these culprits will
soon be found
i open up my app and then i check i see
at 3 50 a.m
i see two suspects around the car lizeth
hernandez recalls the moment she
realized her mother's car was stolen
from their gated community of providence
this happening back on september first
her neighbor across the street getting
hit too all of this on camera you can
see two cars one of which is lazeth's
pulled up next to one another neighbor
around the corner from my house got the
video of
this florida plate
drivers and then my mom's car side by
side so they did a u-turn and then they
both headed out lizeth posting about
this all over social media then she soon
realized she wasn't alone as the same
vehicle involved in her car theft was
seen hanging around other parts of the
community fellow providence resident
joanne says she had her own encounter
with those with plates matching the same
car lizeth posted about someone who had
rang my doorbell they had seen me open
the door and asked me by my name asked
for me by name asked for my husband by
name
and then told me they were with the nra
last week i had an officer from metro
called me
and
asked me what had happened with my
situation and he said that this has been
reported in joann's situation she
recalled these individuals driving
around at all hours of the evening
sitting in their vehicles casing
neighborhoods and sitting in front of
homes for hours
as for lizette's car she was able to get
it back a week later however the vehicle
is severely damaged as of now a good
majority of the sky canyon providence
community keeping an eye out for each
other
also stating that metro has really
stepped up patrol in the area of course
if you know anything you were urged to
contact police immediately reporting
live addison kimbrough 8 news now